ever wondered how your food made its
Journey from the soil to your plate have
you given thought to the traditional
farming techniques at work let's take a
step back in time before the era of
drones and self-driving tractors when
farming was a labor of love a testament
to human perseverance this was the world
of traditional farming a world where the
farmer and the Earth were intimately
connected in these times farming was a
physically demanding Endeavor the work
of hands and simple tools plows were
drawn by beasts of Burden seeds were
sewn by hand and harvests were reaped
with sides and
sickles it was a timec consuming process
with farmers at the mercy of the
elements rain Sun wind and frost each
played a hand in the success or failure
of the crops the challenges were many
pests and diseases could wipe out an
entire season's work in the blink of an
eye soil degradation was a constant
battle as repeated planting and
harvesting stripped the Earth of its
nutrients and let's not forget the sheer
physical toll on the farmers themselves
working long hours Under the Sun and the
rain but it wasn't all hardship and
struggle traditional farming had its
merits too Farmers had a deep
understanding of the land and the cycles
of nature they practiced crop rotation
and mixed farming techniques that
maintained soil fertility and
biodiversity they relied on natural
predators to keep pests in check and
their Farms were self- sustaining
ecosystems yet as efficient as these
methods may have been in their time they
were not without their impact on the
environment deforestation soil erosion
and loss of biodiversity were some of
the unfortunate side effects of
traditional
farming while these techniques have fed
Generations one man believed there had
to be a better way meet the man who
dared to question the status
quo in the heart of the countryside
under the vast open Skies a seed of
curiosity sprouted in the mind of a
seemingly ordinary individual he was a
man rooted in Tradition yet destined to
disrupt it raised in a family of farmers
his hands were no strangers to the soil
and his heart no stranger to the rhythm
of
Seasons yet his mind wasn't content with
simply following the footprints left by
Generations before him our protagonist
Journey began with a simple question a
question that challenged the very ethos
of traditional
farming why he wondered must we rely
solely on the methods passed down
through the generations
could there be a better more efficient
way to cultivate our lands and nourish
our people the road to Innovation as we
know is often Laden with obstacles and
our visionary's path was no
different skepticism met his queries and
resistance met his
ideas yet beneath the weight of doubt
and the shadow of uncertainty his
resolve didn't waver his belief in the
potential for change was as steady as
the tides and as resilient as the crops
he tended to he toiled day and night
experimenting with different techniques
testing new tools and exploring the vast
expanse of knowledge available he wasn't
deterred by the failures nor was he
swayed by the fleeting
triumphs his Focus remained steadfast on
his ultimate goal to revolutionize the
way we Farm the struggles were real the
challenges immense and the journey
exhausting but so was his
determination he weathered the storms of
criticism
navigated the fog of uncertainty and
trudged through the fields of adversity
his vision for a better more sustainable
and efficient way of farming remained
his Guiding Light Illuminating the path
forward Against All Odds he persevered
and eventually came up with a
revolutionary farming technique now
let's delve into the heart of this
revolutionary farming technique imagine
an orchestra where every instrument has
its unique sound but together they
create a harmonious Symphony this is the
essence of our man's farming technique a
symphony of nature it's not just about
growing crops it's about creating an
ecosystem where Every Creature from the
tiniest microorganism to the largest
mammal plays a crucial role ditching the
conventional plow and spray model this
technique uses a method called
permaculture permaculture is a system of
agricultural design that mimics the
patterns and features observed in
natural ecosystems it's centered around
three core tenets care for the Earth
care for the people and fair share
in stark contrast to traditional
monoculture farming which grows single
crops in large Fields this method
encourages diversity different plants
are grown together their Roots
intertwining and their leaves
overlapping this not only maximizes
space but also creates a symbiotic
relationship between the plants they
help each other grow ward off pests and
improve soil fertility and here's where
the science kicks in this technique
leverages the power of nature Itself by
fostering a healthy soil teeming with
microorganisms it ensures plants get all
the nutrients they need it's a
self-sustaining system where the waste
from one element becomes the resource
for another the benefits are manifold
for the farmer it means less Reliance on
expensive and harmful chemical
fertilizers and pesticides it also
requires less water making it ideal for
Regions where water is scarce but the
benefits extend beyond the farm this
method encourages biodiversity which is
crucial for a healthy Planet it reduces
soil erosion helps combat climate change
by sequestering carbon and even creates
habitats for wildlife and the best part
the food produced is healthier and
tastier too because the plants are grown
naturally without any chemical
interventions they are more
nutrient-dense and let's not forget they
are grown with love and love is the
secret ingredient to everything
delicious this is not just a farming
technique it's a philosophy a way of
life it's about living in harmony with
nature about respecting every life form
about giving back to the Earth as much
as we take from it it's about creating a
world where our children and their
children can Thrive it's a technique
that challenges everything we thought we
knew about farming so what does this
mean for the future of
farming let's Ponder this for a moment
the impact of this groundbreaking
technique is far reaching it's more than
just a new method it's a reimagining of
how we approach Agriculture and as with
any sign ific Innovation it has the
potential to revolutionize the
industry first let's talk about
scalability imagine the potential of
this technique if it were adopted on a
larger scale small scale Farmers could
see a substantial increase in their
yield while larger commercial Farms
could benefit from more efficient use of
their land and resources this could lead
to a significant boost in food
production addressing one of the most
pressing issues of our time food
security but what's been the response
from the farming Community well as with
any change it's been a mix of excitement
and skepticism many are eager to embrace
new techniques that could make their
work easier and more productive while
others are hesitant fearing the
unknown yet the success stories we've
shared today are slowly but surely
tipping the scales towards acceptance
and
adoption and let's not forget about
environmental sustainability another
critical concern of our era traditional
farming methods can be harsh on the land
leading to soil degradation and loss of
biodiversity however this Innovative
technique presents a more harmonious
approach it works with nature not
against it promoting healthier soil and
a more diverse ecosystem in essence this
new farming technique isn't just about
growing crops more efficiently it's
about cultivating a better future for us
all it's about creating a sustainable
food secure future where farmers are
empowered and the environment is
respected
as we look to the Future it's clear that
Innovative farming techniques like this
could hold the key to feeding our
growing population sustainably as we
wrap up let's reflect on the power of
innovation the journey we've taken today
from the traditional approach to farming
through the Revolutionary techniques of
a Visionary has shown us the profound
impact of innovative thinking it's not
just about making tasks easier or saving
time it's about addressing Global
challenges about ensuring our Survival
on this beautiful planet we've seen how
one man's shocking farming technique has
revolutionized the agricultural sector
this is a testament to the fact that no
field is beyond the reach of innovation
it's about looking at what we have the
challenges we face and asking how can we
do this better but Innovation isn't just
for the Selected Few each one of us can
contribute to this continuous journey of
progress whether you're a student a
professional a homemaker or a retiree
your ideas can bring about change so
don't underestimate the power of your
thoughts your questions remember every
revolutionary idea begins with a single
question what will your question
be